Kazajistán,  la última de las
repúblicas soviéticas en declarar su
independencia, es un vasto país de 2
millones 725 mil kilómetros cuadrados.
Es decir, es más grande que la suma de
los tamaños de España, Portugal, Francia,
Alemania, Italia, Holanda, Reino Unido,
Irlanda, Suiza, Austria y Polonia
¡casi nada!
A pesar de ello, su población es de poco
más de 18 millones de habitantes, con lo
que ya os podéis imaginar que Kazajistán
es un país prácticamente despoblado.
Hablamos de una tierra dura y hostil,
dominada sobre todo por áridas estepas
y cuyas temperaturas, ojo, oscilan entre
los 40 grados en verano y los 40 grados
bajo cero en invierno. Claro, por ello
instalaron aquí muchos de los gulags
o campo de trabajos forzosos de la era
soviética.
Bueno, seguro que alguno se pregunta ¿por
qué hablamos en VisualPolitik de un
país que no resulta tan desconocido y
está lejano? Por varias razones:
En primer lugar, Kazajistán es un país
con una posición estratégica entre
oriente y occidente, y de hecho es uno de
los integrantes de la Unión Económica
Euroasiática, la especie de Unión
Europea impulsada por la Rusia de
Vladimir Putin. Y, además, juega, también,
un papel destacado en el proyecto chino
conocido como "La Nueva Ruta de la Seda",
un programa logístico muy ambicioso que
pretende impulsar con enormes
inversiones las conexiones por tierra
y mar entre China y Europa. - "En la actualidad
las mercancías de China necesitan una
media de 42 días para llegar a Europa
por mar, y la nueva logística e
infraestructuras de transporte pretenden
reducir este tiempo a una media de 13
días". En segundo lugar, y aunque parezca
sorprendente, España mantiene unas
relaciónes relativamente estrechas con
esta república. Y, en tercer lugar, el
punto clave, Kazajistán es un país muy
rico en recursos naturales que durante
muchos años fue conocido como el Dubai
de la Estepa.
Por cierto, aunque arrendado por Rusia
hasta el año 2050,
en este país se ubica el Cosmódromo de
Baikonour, el corazón del programa
espacial soviético y hoy el centro de
lanzamientos más importantes del mundo.
El presidente de Kazajistán es Nursultán Nazarbáyev, y
lo lleva siendo ininterrumpidamente
desde la independencia del país.
Bueno, ya antes, desde 1984, era el primer
ministro de la República Socialista
Soviética de Kazajistán y, por tanto, el
mandamás local. Por cierto,
su trayectoria es bastante particular porque
pasó de ser ateo a musulmán
practicante, y de comunista a
mercantilista.
Aunque formalmente Kazajistán es una
democracia, de facto es una dictadura.
El culto al líder es omnipresente,
algunas estimaciones, ojo, calculan que
las empresas dirigidas por el entorno del
líder suponen, ni más ni menos, que el 50
por ciento de la economía nacional. Y,
por supuesto, tal y como denuncia
Amnistía Internacional, las torturas, la
represión, la censura y el cierre de
medios de comunicación son norma
habitual.
Por ello, no sorprende que en las últimas
elecciones presidenciales celebradas en
abril de 2015,
Nazarbáyev obtuviese el 97,5 por ciento
de los votos y que en las últimas
legislativas su partido se hiciese con
76 de los 98 escaños en disputa.
- "La Organización para la Cooperación y
el Desarrollo Económico ha expresado su
preocupación sobre la transparencia de
estos comicios,
dado que el país ocupa uno de los
puestos más bajos en la clasificación
de los estándares democráticos".
Las elecciones de 2011 fueron aún más
descaradas porque el "líder" no solo no
hizo campaña, sino que uno de los tres
candidatos de la oposición llegó a
jactarse de haber votado por él.
Kazajistán es un país muy rico en
recursos naturales: sus reservas de
petróleo son las onceavas mayores del
mundo, es el mayor productor y exportador
de uranio y es, también, un actor
destacado en cuanto a reservas de oro,
tierras raras, zinc, hierro y un largo
etcétera de minerales. Debido a ello el
país atrajo muchísima inversión, y con
el último boom en los precios del
petróleo y las materias primas la
economía se disparó, registrando muchos
años incluso crecimientos de doble
dígito.
Así, desde su independencia en 1991,
el PIB del país se ha multiplicado por 9 y,
entre 2004 y 2014, incluida la crisis
internacional,
el país registró un crecimiento medio
del 6,5 por ciento anual.
Además, con el dinero del petróleo se
constituyó un fondo nacional que hoy acumula
más de 60.000 millones en inversiones y
desde el año 2000 se han generado casi dos
millones de puestos de trabajo.
En este entorno, el régimen comenzó a
gastar mucho dinero en obras públicas,
la élite cercana al gobierno hizo
grandes fortunas y los proyectos
inmobiliarias se multiplicaron. Astaná,
la capital del país, pasó en pocos
años de tener unos 250.000 habitantes, a
más de 850.000. En este tiempo la ciudad
se lleno de anchas avenidas, grandes
rascacielos y espectaculares centros
comerciales diseñados por los más
prestigiosos arquitectos internacionales.
Y las expectativas erán aún mejores
porque está previsto que en 2017
entre a funcionar un nuevo mega
yacimiento en el Mar Caspio capaz de
duplicar la producción de petróleo
hasta los 3 millones de barriles al día,
situando a Kazajistán entre los diez
mayores productores del mundo.
Por todo ello pronto se empezó a
calificar a este país y, especialmente,
a su capital como la "Dubai de la estepa".
El éxito económico parecía absoluto.
Sin embargo, la inversión pública,
los bajos impuestos - porque aquí la
presión fiscal viene a ser de un 14% y los
tipos son relativamente bajos - o la mano
de obra barata, no fueron suficientes
para transformar el modelo productivo
del país, tal y como el gobierno
pretendía. La dependencia de las
materias primas, sobre todo del petróleo,
no sólo no se superó, sino que incluso
se incrementó desde el año 2000. Así
que, cuando en 2014 comenzó a caer el
precio del petróleo, la economía
nacional hizo lo mismo.
Desde entonces, la moneda del país se ha
devaluado más de
un 25% encareciendo con ello un montón el
costo de vida de sus gentes.
. "Vladimir Putin propone a sus aliados
kazajo y bielorruso crear una unión
monetaria regional para hacer frente
común contra la crisis". El déficit
público no petrolero ha superado el 12
por ciento, el sector público se ha
convertido en la segunda fuente de
empleo tras la agricultura, y ya se ha
consumido casi la quinta parte de todos
los ahorros nacionales en estímulos
económicos.
Lo cierto es que a pesar de los
rascacielos de Astaná y de la gran
riqueza generada por el petróleo, más
del 70 por ciento de la población tiene
unos ingresos de menos de cinco dólares
diarios. En Kazajistán, una oligarquía
extractiva se apoderó por completo de
los recursos nacionales. Llegados a este
punto nos podemos preguntar: ¿qué
diferencia a Dubai de Kazajistán?
No, no es la mano de obra barata del
sudeste asiático, y desde luego no son
los ingresos del petróleo. Como vimos en
un vídeo anterior,
el impresionante crecimiento de Dubai
se debe a su apuesta por abrirse al
comercio y al transporte mundial, por
facilitar las negocios, garantizar la
seguridad jurídica y establecer un
marco normativo muy atractivo para la
inversión y las empresas.
Kazajistán, en cambio, es casi lo
contrario. Es uno de los países más
corruptos del mundo,  la compraventa de
tierra está prácticamente vetada a los
extranjeros, no es un lugar fácil para
hacer negocios,
de hecho la seguridad jurídica brilla
por su ausencia, y el proteccionismo es
una política nacional.
Muchos sectores son monopolios u
oligopolios pertenecientes, bien al
estado, o bien a la oligarquía que rodea
al líder. - "A pesar de las muchas
campañas en contra de la corrupción
algunas de estas prácticas siguen
existiendo, el sector semiestelar está
creciendo". Como hemos visto también en
Venezuela, los recursos naturales nunca
son la clave del éxito. Es posible que
Kazajistán pueda estabilizar su
economía y, desde luego, su situación no es
excesivamente grave, pero ni ha vivido
milagro económico alguno, ni se puede
comparar con Dubái en ningún caso.
Aunque resulte extraño, España ha cuajado unas
relaciones bilaterales bastante
estrechas con este país.
De hecho tanto Aznar, como Zapatero y
Rajoy han realizado visitas oficiales;
los encuentros bilaterales entre
ministros y cargos del gobierno son
frecuentes; y el rey emérito, Juan
Carlos I, es amigo personal de
Nazarbáyev.
Sorprende la capacidad de nuestros dignatarios para llevarse
también con algunos de los gobiernos
más corruptos de la tierra, como ya
vimos, por ejemplo, con la Guinea
Ecuatorial de Teodoro Obiang. Sobre todo
cuando tenemos en cuenta que las
relaciones comerciales entre Kazajistán
y España son insignificantes, a
excepción, eso sí, de unas pocas
empresas como Repsol o Talgo ¿Tendrá eso
algo que ver?
Bueno, ¿qué pensáis vosotros? ¿Conviene
llevarse bien con este tipo de dictaduras?
¿Es Dubái la excepción que confirma la
regla respecto a la llamada enfermedad
de los recursos naturales?
¿Os gustaría visitar Kazajistán? Espero
que os haya gustado este vídeo y si ha
sido así
no dudéis en darle a like y suscribiros
al canal. Un saludo y hasta la próxima.